there's no other way to say it the world
is divided on nfts and it's not an easy
50 50 split it's not a cut down the
center like north and south korea it's
more like a 90 10 thing where most
people don't understand nfds or think
they're way overvalued and you have the
10 percent who'd rather have a board ape
yacht club than have an actual yacht
club right now the war is pretty even
you got the 10 believers all on twitter
screaming every day while the 90 are
more like cool jpeg bro but recently the
battle has been heating up as the icon
of american culture keanu reeves
weighed in he was asked about an nft
collection coming up with matrix
resurrection and he didn't hold back his
opinions let's just say that bring down
the board i get into it dodge it dude i
haven't hit my head in
years dude years all right let's watch
they made uh nfts for the new movie and
there were like 100 000 of them and the
site broke like in the first few hours
because there were over 300 000 people
in the queue trying to buy these nfts
for 50 and so like when you think about
the concept of digital scarcity and
things that are
you know they can't be copied that are
easily reproduced
well
but they're not the same right oh boy
that's painful on the one hand you got
you got the reporter being like well
they're not the same right right i just
spent a lot of money on those i think
it's just cackling like he's trying out
for the lion king hyena role
but they're not the same right and you
know what i'm gonna say this right now i
think the nft nft bros deserve it a
little bit yeah i'm gonna say it i know
it's a controversial take i know i'm
gonna get in trouble but hey you guys
have
had this coming a little bit now look
you guys know i love the part of nfts
that's like let's get digital artist
spade okay great that's that's cool but
right now it feels like the nft market's
more like about getting derivative cash
grabs you know what i mean like it's not
about art as much as it is exploiting
artists and getting them hiring a bunch
of kids on fiverr to go make you know 10
000 profile pics so you can profit
here's the thing you're gonna get hate
if you do that it's and so i feel like
it's not everybody's fault in the nft
community there's obviously a lot of
great people and i'm sure it's the
idiots getting the most attention which
is unfortunate but those people are
poisoning the well for everybody else
because it just feels like everybody's
got an nft collection right now and it
just turns it into something that's
really not special it's kind of stupid
it literally feels like people are
jumping into nfts just so they can prove
they're like ahead of the curve or
whatever and you know what i have a
proposal to fix this um because i don't
want nfts to get ruined i propose that
only actual artists can sell art in fts
from now on
no hey listen and i know that sounds
like i'm gatekeeping who am i to say who
can post an nft but um
okay you're right it does sound pretty
gatekeepy uh maybe this
if you're a marketer if you're if you
know who i'm talking about um the guys
who watch garyvee all day yeah those
guys can't have an open c account i
feel like that would fix all this
somehow and you know it's weird right
because it feels like this just all
started as let's help the artists
whatever and then it's you know it's a
bunch of influencers trying to tell you
you're going to get rich and you're not
and this is the part i really want to
hit on right
my petition to ban
banned marketers from open c look the
reason is is because
they're only in in it for one reason and
that's
they don't care about the tack right
they don't care about
art what they care about is money right
they care about all the money in it it's
the same reason that kickstarter uh
actually just joined the blockchain i
don't know if you guys saw this they
decided they're suddenly into it the
reason being it seems to me because you
know people like the constitution dao
those guys who are trying to buy the
constitution they raised more money just
by themselves no crowdfunding platform
in one go than kickstarter has ever
raised for anything so obviously
kickstarter saw this and we're like all
right well i guess
i guess we're in the blockchain business
now and it feels like that's happening a
lot people have noticed how much money
is in nfts and everyone's just flocking
into that industry whether or not they
fit
and that's the thing that uh is kind of
annoying i mean look not everybody needs
an nft collection like
if you're a mailman you might not need
an nft collection and you're thinking oh
that's a joke no i mean look dude
beverage companies are jumping in
we're one step away from ups doing it
too look at this at least actually it
would make more sense drops i mean look
at this budverse nft giveaway
what is that pepsi same thing they just
dropped the pepsi mic drop
i mean have these guys forgotten that
they serve
beverages that's what you do we're in
the middle of a pandemic they're supply
chain shortages and what are they
worried about their nft drops going well
yeah guys that's
that's the most important thing in fact
pepsi's isn't going so well um they had
a bunch of bots immediately snipe
snipe their their mint or their white
list and so now they're they're working
to make sure that only humans get it
so that's where our attention is going
that's where our time's going i mean
you know it's just stupid that's that's
what i guess what i'm saying is like
okay
is keanu reeves you know right to just
dismiss the whole industry and laugh at
it well
but they're not the same right a little
bit it is funny it i i get it so i feel
like we're reaching just sort of peak
insanity with nfts and for someone to
come out and just sort of
laugh at the whole thing and be like
wait what are we so into
i really do think it's funny and maybe a
little bit deserved um even though the
tech is cool and you know i love artists
actual artists getting their bag you
know i i don't really care to see gary v
make another you know billion dollars
that's not really my dream right but
either way when people end up coming up
with some more actual use cases for nfts
i'll be singing your praises but for now
i'm just gonna laugh along with keanu
cause
it's pretty funny all right that's
basically it i'll see you in the next
one